If you have ever stumbled onto one of those
click bait list articles with titles, like
world's top 10 smartest people, then you might
have seen this name come up.
William James Sidis.
His name is often included in these lists
alongside a claim that his IQ is between 250
and 300.
For context that is higher than any recorded
result and anything above 140 is considered
genius.
People like Steven Hawking and Einstein are
said to have IQs around 160.
Now, from what I can tell this claim about
William Sidis' IQ seems highly dubious.
In fact, I can't find any evidence that he
ever took an IQ test.
It was his sister who said that a psychologist
had once measured his IQ to be between 250
and 300.
But that might have come about from a misunderstanding
or an exaggeration when William did write
to his sister saying that he had just taken
a civil service exam for which he scored 254th
on the list of candidates.
But he himself described that as not so encouraging.
What is true about William Sidis is that he
was very intelligent and he was a child prodigy.
The New York Times was reporting about him
when he was 10 years old and had just passed
the MIT entrance exam.
It says that when he was two, he could read
and write.
And when he was four, he could speak four
languages.
What is also true about William Sidis is that
he has a very interesting story.
And I'll share that story in this video, as
well as share some of the work that he left
behind.
He set the record for the youngest person
to enroll at Harvard at age 11.
And at age 12, he gave a lecture there on
four dimensional bodies.
William's father, Boris Sidis was a psychiatrist
and his mother, Sarah was a doctor.
They had a lot of thoughts about developmental
psychology and put a lot of effort into raising
William to be a prodigy.
They spent any spare money on books and learning
tools for him and nurtured his hunger for
knowledge.
William Sidis was named after his dad's friend,
William James, who was a philosopher and psychologist.
It was Boris Sidis and William James, who
together came up with the idea that we only
use 10% of our brains.
And they tested this theory on young William.
When William showed great talents in learning,
it was seen as proof that most people only
meet a fraction of their full mental potential.
It was called the reserve energy theory and
Boris was trying to unlock his son's reserve
energy.
This 10% of the brain idea is largely considered
a myth now with Wikipedia saying that it rests
in folklore, not science, and that brain mapping
suggests that all areas of the brain have
a function and that they are used nearly all
of the time, but keep that reserve energy
theory in your mind, because it's important
to this story in unexpected ways.
Life as a child, prodigy, wasn't easy for
William.
He was constantly reported on and struggled
to fit in with older students, both at school
and university.
After he graduated his degree, he told reporters
that he wanted to live the perfect life, which
to him meant living in seclusion.
He abandoned further studies in maths and
law, and even got arrested for participating
in a political parade.
After that incident, his parents tried to
reform him, but he soon became estranged from
them and went on to live a very independent
and private life.
He ended up suing The New Yorker for an article
they published about him calling him lonely
and invading his privacy.
The sentiment of that article as well as many
modern footnotes about him seemed to imply
that despite his great early promise, he amounted
to nothing or that he suffered a complete
mental breakdown due to being pushed too hard,
mentally as a child by his parents.
But in all those years of William Sidis living
outside of the public eye, he was still learning
and writing and sharing knowledge.
He published many books under pseudonyms,
but I have one here that he published under
his own name.
It is called The Animate and The Inanimate,
and it was published in 1920 when he was 22.
It details a theory of his that relates to
cosmology, physics and life.
So let's have a look through it.
Sidis says that this work is based on the
idea of the reversibility of everything in
time.
That is that all of the physical laws work
backwards, but there is one exception and
that is the second law of thermodynamics.
The second law relates to the idea that say,
you have a bunch of particles in a box.
They might start off all concentrated in one
corner, but over time they will spread out.
And it's so extremely unlikely that they would
all collect in that corner again, that we
consider it to be impossible . With this we
see that the flow of heat goes from hot to
cold.
You don't see water spontaneously turning
into ice because this is such an unlikely
flow of energy.
Then Sidis mentions the idea of Maxwell's
demon, that if you were to have a reversal
of this second law of thermodynamics, that
you could imagine a sorting demon who could
separate the slower particles from the faster
ones, a demon could do this by monitoring
some kind of barrier between two halves of
the box, only letting slow particles into
the left hand side and fast particles into
the right.
You'd see that left hand side of the box become
cold and the right hand side become hot.
Something that wouldn't naturally happen,
but seems to have made available some kind
of energy flow between hot and cold.
The second law of thermodynamics also brought
in the idea of entropy, which is constantly
increasing and for the next hundred or so
pages William Sidis explores the idea that
perhaps in some regions of space, we do see
a reversal of the second law of thermodynamics.
And in these regions, entropy flows in the
other direction.
He also claims that perhaps these regions
are what we know as life, that instead of
defining life as something that is able to
reproduce or grow or respond to the environment
that we instead define it as something that
is able to take what we might have thought
of as unavailable energy and turn it into
a reserve fund of energy used only by life
and created by non-living forces.
And then he mentions the work of his father's
friend, professor William James, who discovered
in the domain of mental phenomena, what he
calls reserve energy.
That's that whole 10% of the brain idea.
So William Sidis is taking this idea that
he has been raised to believe in and that
his father was heavily involved with.
And perhaps he credits for the reason he is
called the prodigy and tries to apply it to
physics, to thermodynamics and the laws of
the universe.
He does mention that this work is purely speculative
and that there are no experiments to verify
what he suggests.
This work never really reached an audience.
And perhaps that made Sidis feel despondent
about it, and he didn't publish any more known
works of physics.
This work was pretty much unknown until it
was rediscovered in an attic in 1979.
Now let's take a little look through some
more of the chapters.
The first few chapters look at some of the
physical laws and explore what they might
look like in a reverse universe.
He says that in the real universe, energy
runs down to a common level and in the reverse
universe, energy tends to build itself up
into different levels.
In the real universe, we would see an ultimate
heat death mentioned here as when all of the
energy is in the form of heat it's least concentrated
form and at a uniform concentration.
A dead level of energy would be reached.
And after that, nothing further could ever
happen in the universe.
That's unless heat was able to build itself
up into different levels and be converted
back into mechanical or kinetic energy as
in a reverse universe.
Now, I don't mean to make any of this sound
too believable, and there are many dubious
claims in here we've got here the requirement
that the mechanical efficiency in the reverse
universe is over a hundred percent, just like
how the second law of thermodynamics is really
an overwhelming probability rather than a
law.
So too is its reversal that in this reverse
universe, these probabilities are weighted
in the opposite direction.
Sidis believes that tracing back, there must
be a time in the past when the available energy
was a hundred percent of the total universe,
and there must have been what he called a
great collision, where everything was at a
temperature of absolute zero.
And there were two semi universes, which were
moving towards each other in each of which
there was not even a trace of relative motion.
Sidis believes that in our own universe, 50%
of cases will obey the second law of thermodynamics.
And in 50% of the cases, it will be reversed.
The universe as a whole will be neutral.
So where apparently is all of this reverse
universe, hiding?
Well Sidis believed that there were vast pockets
of space that have a tendency towards the
positive direction and other pockets that
have a tendency in the reverse direction.
That the universe is made up of a number of
what we may call bricks, ultimately positive
and negative, all approximately the same volume
arranged sort of like a three dimensional
checkerboard.
That what we see is simply the white space
that we are in.
The black spaces surrounding us are invisible.
In them the laws of thermodynamics would be
predominantly reversed.
The stars in those black spaces would be reverse
stars that instead of giving out light, they
absorb light.
This is an intriguing part of his discussion
because he's doing a good job of describing
what we would now call black holes.
He calls these reverse stars, perfectly black
bodies.
These stars use radiant energy to build up
a higher level of heat.
He says that we can only see stars in the
section of space where the second law of thermodynamics
prevails, but that there is an additional
part of the universe, which is not visible
to us.
These black spaces even absorb the light from
the white spaces beyond them.
So even those cannot be seen by us.
And by looking at the distribution of light
in the sky, we get an idea merely of the size
and shape of our special white space.
And if you think that Sidis is predicting
the existence of black holes here, keep in
mind, this is 47 years before the term black
hole was even first used and almost 20 years
before Chandrasekhar even theorized the existence
of something like a black hole.
He says the boundary surface is between the
positive and negative sections of space that
when light crosses it, it crosses in one direction
from the positive side to the negative side.
If we were on the positive side, as seems
to be the case, then we could not see beyond
such surface though.
We might easily have gravitational or other
evidence of bodies existing beyond the surface.
And that seems to have a lot in common with
what we know as the event horizon.
Sidis then mentions a supernova and suggest
that the flaring up of a star must be it changing
over from the negative to the positive tendency
that in the universe stars will be constantly
crossing over from one section to the next
and that when this happens and a star crosses
over from a positive to a negative section
of the universe, there happens a slow process
of development of life growth, changing the
star from a positive one to a negative one
gradually.
And here you can start to see where the title
of this book comes from The Animate and The
Inanimate.
Sidis says that inanimate phenomena are positive
tendencies and follow the second law of thermodynamics
while animate phenomena on the contrary are
negative tendencies and tend to reverse that
law.
There's a motivation behind a lot of these
stranger connections, which comes from the
fact that at the time this book was written
around 1920, there was a lot about biology
and living processes that we didn't understand.
And we have learned so much more since then,
the way that biological processes work within
living bodies and the way that cells process
energy is much less of a mystery to us now.
And a lot of what we know about biology wouldn't
stack up against some of these claims, even
the way our own brains work was a lot less
understood.
Sidis calls it a central organ in which the
reserve energy is stored.
And it seems that if he had been raised in
any other family, he probably wouldn't have
had that idea and been trying to draw that
kind of a connection.
Some of the claims get more and more dubious
as the pages go on, but Sidis himself even
recognizes this and ends with some objections
to his theory.
He emphasizes that this work is only mere
speculation.
One objection is that we have no proof that
life really does reverse the second law of
thermodynamics.
Instead, we have plenty of evidence of living
bodies obeying the second law.
The theory also supposes that life exists
everywhere and under all sorts of circumstances,
but that's in contrast to what we actually
observe when it comes to life.
It instead seems to be an extremely complex
phenomenon that can exist only under very
special circumstances.
Sidis says that he will leave the reader to
compare for themself the theory, and weigh
up the various arguments for and against.
This book remained pretty much unknown for
many decades.
When it was found again in 1979, it was given
to Buckminster Fuller who happened to be a
former Harvard classmate of William Sidis.
Buckminster Fuller gave the work, perhaps
its first proper review.
He said that he felt excitement and joy on
being handed a copy of the book, which he
says clearly predicts the black hole.
So many people commenting on Sidis' life have
said that he amounted to nothing and didn't
use any of his academic brilliance.
But Fuller says here, I hope you'll become
as excited as I am at this discovery that
Sidis did go on after college to do the most
magnificent thinking and writing.
Sidis' work is hard to understand, and we
may never find a place for it within modern
theories, but Sidis himself was also hard
for society to understand.
People poked at his first signs of weakness,
perhaps to feel better about themselves.
William didn't deserve to be lumped with the
pressures of having to continuously prove
his genius.
That a child prodigy would grow up and collapse
under the mental burden of their childhood
is an easier narrative to report on than understanding
the alternative ways that we all try to live
a fulfilling life.
This portion of the video is sponsored by
Skillshare.
If you watched this video, then you are probably
interested in examples of exceptional ability
and ways to reach your own potential.
If you want to learn from experts and foster
your own skills, check out Skillshare, which
is an online learning community with thousands
of online classes, it's a place to get inspired,
learn new skills and put them to work in impactful
ways.
I spent a lot of the last year learning stop
motion animation for Finding X.
And this course from PES is a great intro
to the technique coming from one of the largest
stop motion animators on YouTube.
There's a special link down in the description
and the first 1000 people to click it will
get a one month free trial of Skillshare.
So check it out.
Thank you for watching, a special shout out
to today's Patron Cats of the Day Pan and
Tilt.